uh completely ashkenazi jewish
rewind a little bit more because i grew
up in an all boys catholic school that
synagogue in my grandfather's synagogue
the reason
the the catholicism and the christianity
that we were taught i firmly believe was
different i think it has changed
from the city of levive
and i was taught by italian missionaries
you know you were taught by italian
missionaries like we we had
actual italian missionaries from italy
in our school assalamu alaikum brothers
and sisters this is your brother eddie
from the d show and i have some amazing
news for you we just made a down payment
and are in contract to purchase this 35
000 square foot facility with over four
acres to make it the dean center
alhamdulillah the project includes a
masjid an athletic facility a live
studio for recording the d show and tawa
outreach programs and as you've known
i've been looking for a no interest
owner financing and alhamdulillah i
found this church property for 2.5
million that will do all of it i've
given a hundred thousand dollar down
payment to enter into the contract and
one million dollars will be paid over 36
months inshallah with no interest
alhamdulillah but right now we need 1.4
million to close on this property
brothers and sisters help us purchase
this property to build the dean center
donate right now may god almighty allah
reward all of you brothers and sisters
[Music]
we got an exciting episode live here in
boca raton florida now my next guest
michael joshua knutz
has taught english to immigrants and
spanish to americans on the university
level professionally growing up in such
an exciting
multi-ethnic multi-cultural and
multi-racial
metropolis stimulated his appetite to
learn about different people and
of course religions growing up with a
jewish education as a youth he
intuitively felt that there had to be
much more than what he had been taught
in hebrew school so he began his
spiritual journey and was baptized as a
christian later on went on and studied
in a hedo ashram but still felt that he
had not reached his spiritual
destination
after all that he got exposed to islam
and then he learned about the quran
and prophet muhammad the more he had
been able to the more he had learned
about the quran and prophet muhammad the
more he was able to synthesize and
properly understand the old and the new
testaments he took his shahada just
three years ago and so he's here with us
here today
alhamdulillah alaikum
my name is michael krantz
and it's a great honor to be here on the
dean's show this evening
because
[Laughter]
it was very uh nice to see that you
actually live in bosnia was it bosnia or
which part were you there
well i was a tour guide in
uh
croatia that the dalmatian coast and of
course
if you went to former yugoslavia
you had to go to sarajevo all right so
you spent some time in sarajevo i did
and in mostar as well
and
i was very very
touched in my heart
by the kindness and generosity
of the muslim people there
before in bosnia in bosnia
absolutely so
more than any other part
of europe
i also had the opportunity to
travel through and live in turkey
years earlier
and there i was also very very very
touched
and impressed by the hospitality of the
turkish people the warmth
and natural hospitality wherever i went
people would want to take me places
invite me to restaurants it was
incredible
and
my my multicultural experiences
as a youth were in the bronx new york
which i'm very proud of
so you grew up going to a hebrew school
no i went to a public school all through
secular schools i was not a good student
i hated regular school
so
two to add insult to injury
my parents obliged me to go to hebrew
school two evenings a week which was
torture and so after a while the teacher
realized that i was uncomfortable there
they politely told my parents to remove
me
as a matter of fact
my father
had to teach me
my bar mitzvah which is
a coming-of-age at age 13
as a young man
but not in that synagogue in my
grandfather's synagogue where i didn't
have a bad reputation
so your mother and father jewish
yes actually
my mother
is really ethnically half jewish because
her mother
was from a small protestant slovak
village
in slovakia
so
on my father's side completely ashkenazi
jewish
from the city of levive lviv if you've
been watching the news
you know that this city is in the news
every day
through the terrible war that's
happening
i won't go any farther than that so then
how did you end up from there
actually getting baptized
i was very very music has always been a
great part of my life
and i
really loved bluegrass music
so
okay this was the late 1960s i'm 72
years old
i used to hitchhike
during my school breaks down to the
mountains of west virginia and kentucky
and so
when you make friends you wind up going
to church revival meetings mostly
pentecostal
and one evening i was
touched by the holy spirit and
i accepted jesus as my savior
subsequently after that
there was a hindu ashram in my parents
neighborhood that looked very
interesting too
and i became involved with that
studying
with a
very very renowned swami from madras
india
but i felt intuitively that
my journey was not over and
so
i began to come here to
islamic center of boca raton maybe three
years ago i found out that there was an
open house
and i realized that
islam
respects
moses jesus
and then of course
god's la
final prophet the prophet muhammad peace
be upon him
and everything began to
coalesce
come together
and
three years ago
i took the shahada
and
i'm still
expanding my knowledge of islam
one thing that impressed me
was the warmth and the kindness of the
people here
when i came as a guest
regardless of where people were they
would always come over to me
shake my hand
uh asked
asked where i was from
uh
three years ago
and brother bassam
al-halabi knows that i was
i was crippled
of course handicapped is the more
uh generic word but
i really was and whenever i would go
back into the lobby to put my shoes on
the little children without their
parents prodding them in any way
would all rush over to me
to help me put my shoes on
can you imagine that
little children three four years old
rushing over
to help me put my shoes on seeing
my terrible physical state
and
one night
there weren't many people at the open
house
and i was alone with brother bassem and
his wife maha
brother bassam and maha have a special
way
of teaching the
the essence of islam
and
suddenly sister maha asked me
out of the blue
can you ever become a muslim
and
at that time knowing the shahada i
recited it three times
and
the rest is well that's why i'm here
this evening
all right let me introduce my next guest
alaikum i'm francisco from south florida
i'm here on the dean show and look
forward to sharing my story with you
francisco carrera
who was born and raised in ecuador south
america he attended an all-boys catholic
school and after migrating to the united
states his journey to islam was
triggered by the passing of his father
after
he had just turned 15.
he went on a spiritual search
and while he didn't find what he was
looking for he settled for a few
concepts
he believed in only one god
and believed in doing good
as such he remained spiritual but not
religious
through a religious studies class he
visited the religious center of all
major religions including a mosque in
detroit where he had some amazing coffee
and some baklava he never forgot the
hospitality and the kind gesture
in 2015
he found himself researching the boxing
career of muhammad ali
and was captivated by all the good he
was doing while always giving credit to
his religion islam
and we're not talking about the nation
of farikan we're talking about
submission to the creator not the
creation islam as he had no muslim
friends and he looked up a he was
looking for a muslim servant servant one
video led to another and he found
ended up finding the dean's show
alhamdulillah which is how he got his
first quran
he consciously started to cut back on
drinking and stopped eating pork he
later built up the courage to try to
contact and visit a local masjid
which it took a while for them to
respond but after about a year and a
half
i don't take him a year and have to
respond it took him a year and a half of
studying and research and after all that
he ended up saying
there's nothing worthy of worship except
the creator allah muhammad is his
messenger he took the shahada and he's
also here with us right next to me my
brother
salaam alaikum
how are you doing brother
thank you for joining us in south
florida there was a lot of things thank
you for for
the thank you i'm happy to be here thank
you for the free quran
you're welcome yes
so let's start from there your father
passed away
and that triggered you said that
triggered for you that's when your
journey
began
well my i would rewind a little bit more
because i grew up in an all-boys
catholic school yeah so that spiritual
foundation was there but the the um
the the irony about that is that uh even
as a little boy i don't ever recall
uh fully buying into the concept of what
i was being taught even though i was in
a catholic school since i was little um
but i always believed in god and i
always
but everything else was just basically a
ritual you're a kid you're doing what
you're told and that's that's about it
um then when my father passed away um
yes i went on a spiritual uh
search journey if you may um
you know different people react to the
death of a parent in different ways and
i turned to books i turned to reading
and uh um
at that time
i didn't find islam
the concept was in my mind single god
you know being good
just
serving basically i thought that the
closest thing would be judaism but you
can't really become jewish as far as i
know
and so and and there is uh society kind
of imposes a type of
um of censorship by omission
in the sense that you know these shelves
at the bookstore were filled with
materials from every religion except
islam wow okay
and uh um so i didn't find anything
related to islam and uh
but i knew that that concept that fitra
was there you know it was the same thing
that
that uh eventually led me to it
what were you being taught in catholic
school
you know it's in those days uh 30 plus
years ago
37 years ago
the uh in those days uh for whatever
reason
the the catholicism and the christianity
that we were taught i firmly believe was
different i think it has changed in the
sense that and i was taught by italian
missionaries you know you were taught by
italian missionaries like we we had
actual italian missionaries from italy
in our school so there's no it was a
solution school we didn't even have nuns
past second or third grade so this is
like real orthodox like oh yeah like
real like like the real deal like no
bidder no like or as far as they in in
their version that was it you know
and i always thought a hierarchy you
know and i think that in many ways you
know that the father was
god
and the son was was up there he was a
vip but he was not god so that's in
since i was little
that's kind of like the concept that i
that i held of of jesus christ peace be
upon him you see and so
the uh
yes he was special
i think we i think we put more emphasis
on on mother mary peace upon her you
know i think that that's uh um we we
would find ourselves praying to mary
more than to jesus
so the compromise compromises that
you're seeing today
it's a big difference it's different and
and i think that it's kind of i don't
think i'm going too crazy because if you
ask my mother who's not muslim yet um
the uh if you ask her
if jesus is god she'll say no
that's how she grew up you see and and
if you ask her who's jesus you say he's
a prophet he was a man he lived he died
or whatnot but he she doesn't elevate
him to the status of god so there was
something different in the way that
christianity was being relayed in those
days nowadays it's different now yes uh
the the whole
trinity concept uh at least as far as i
come to experience with with uh with
others yes they they merge the three
into one you see but i don't recall that
being the case i was taught more of a
hierarchy so the transition into islam
was not that difficult because at the
end you know i
in my eyes jesus was not god you see
what what about the crucifixion
that was all there but i would argue it
was more in my
as a kid and from what i recall from
what i remember it was more like
fluff it was just more just their
history
but it was not
i i never understood the whole concept
of jesus dying for your sins and things
like they didn't make any sense to me it
just doesn't uh um so
but i believed in god you see and i
believe that there was a higher being
and i believe that in in in doing being
a good person and that we're here to
serve and all these other things so
that's why
eventually when i was in my spiritual
search
um you know that those were the concepts
that i held on to but i could never find
because like you know censorship by a
mission you know it's just not it wasn't
there it was impressive and it took
another 15 years or so
um
just in researching the
like i mentioned the boxing career of
muhammad ali
um and suddenly i was
more
i was more fascinated by his life's work
by his o'clock in in how he helped
people and all over the world and how he
felt comfortable with
the poor people and he had this glow on
his face
and
seeing that i was like that's what i
want you know and he would always give
credit to his religion so
that's it you see
he always
turned back and said this is
he gave credit why did his sponsor in
one way or another he never
he never hid it
and
and i think that as an uma
we need to work a little bit more on
that being more upfront and be more open
about the fact that we're muslims and
sharing that because we have the right
we have the right religion we have to
write principles we have to write things
for the whole world to witness that
and naturally come to islam who's not
going to like our concepts everybody's
going to like our concepts because
they're beautiful and um the uh but i
think where we where we one of the
things that we need to work on
is
sharing that with the world and as part
of my of my journey you know how did i
get exposed to it it was through like i
said his interviews right because he
wasn't he wasn't ashamed of talking
about it right he was proud of talking
about it and then later on as time went
along you know that caught my attention
and as time went along
you know in my gym who did i see i saw
hijabi working out and she would always
be covered and she would be
you know
in the midst of a gym with
all these american women the way that
they work out she was always
you know covered and she was steadfast
in a sense right and i think women are
given a beautiful privilege a beautiful
uh
status in islam a beautiful gift from
allah in that
when they walk into a room and if they
have a hijab on everybody knows
immediately they're muslim right and i
think that's why governments nowadays
are so afraid of it you see because it's
so powerful
and
and how a sister
behaves you know how she carries herself
is so important because she's not just
representing herself she's representing
that religion at that moment you see so
um men don't have that privilege i walk
into a room nobody notices but women
have that privilege so in in that gym
environment i was like that's cool you
know and then with her husband they
invited like a coach
that we had who was a
complete right-winger right and he uh
they invited him over for ramadan
and
i was over here in this conversation i
never told them that
i was probably five or eight feet away
and
they invited the coach over for ramadan
and as a right winger he's like no no
i'm not gonna go to the you know muslim
home or whatever they invited him over i
guess now i know it's iftar that's the
first time i heard ramadan
and from that moment on i wanted to try
ramadan and that stuck with me for the
years to come as i was researching islam
so do you feel a lot of people get stuck
there where they believe in god
and in doing good but then like you
you don't associate you got to a point
where you weren't associating with any
religion no
i wasn't i bet it was more you see a lot
of that happening nowadays do you see
people they're just like okay i don't
wanna because they associate you know
many strange things and you know they
can see through all the fluff with all
the man-made religions and they just
kind of i think that if you look at
if you look at organized religion yeah
quote-unquote right they say i don't
want to follow any organized religion
and they organize religion and the
biggest growing sector
aside from islam is people calling
themselves spiritual but not religious
that's another religion
but what is that they're believing in
god and being good none of them are
going to believe in god and being evil
they're not going to believe in 10 gods
or something like that you know if you
ask them that what spiritual but not
religions means to them it means that
yeah there's a creator that's why
they're spiritual you know but not
religious why because they see all this
you know bitters going on with these
other religions all this other stuff
that's going on so they don't want to
associate with that and that's why they
call themselves spiritual but not
religious so we have an opportunity as
muslims to
to be more open about our religion
wear it proudly
carry yourself properly you know when
you when you dress up dress up well um
you know when when you speak speak well
smile at people be gentle be open
right uh so that
and then complement that with
being open about being muslim because
people are going to notice and people
are watching and i can say that from
experience i was watching and i never
said a thing and i was watching for a
long time
you see and
and that's what part of the reason why i
came to islam eventually
um so you mentioned that during the
introduction that
one of the factors that moved me out of
christianity was
the
shift in the beliefs within this time
frame where you saw the status of jesus
jesus being elevated to a level where it
was not
originally
what do you think is the barrier for
people from your generation who should
be able to see that shift very clearly
but somehow they just don't
focus on that and they still are not
wondering over
what what actually is happening the
question has come up very often in our
open house
seminars
for me
becoming a muslim
was really really so easy for the simple
reason that
i understood i
i i always
okay backing up
i never ever equated
jesus christ
as a god
in many many christian religions
i would say in the majority of christian
religions
jesus christ is equated as a god and as
francisco mentioned
not
too long ago
in the roman catholic church
pope john paul ii
actually elevated the virgin mary
to
to be like like a god to be divine
uh there can only be and i suppose this
goes back to my jewish heritage there
can only be one god one creator
there can be prophets and
as we know in islam
allah has sent down many many prophets
to many peoples all over the world
islam also respects
all of the holy people in the old
testament
as we just as we just discussed
jesus peace be upon him
is the second major prophet
and then the prophet muhammad of course
is god's final messenger
so
this synthesized everything for me it
became so
so clear that
that here
was the correct sequence and the correct
understanding
of moses musa jesus
and the prophet muhammad and there can
only be
one god it was just discussed that
many many people are leaving
organized religion the latest statistic
that i read online
from a reputable website
was that 65 percent of american people
no longer go to
a church a synagogue
and i'm sure lamentedly sometimes there
are even some some muslim people who
have fallen away
i'll pass the microphone to francisco i
i hope that answered
part of your question
personally i i believe that
there just needs to be more openness
about speaking
about religion right
the glasses through which
the christian community is taught to see
and read the bible
that filter the filter of the gla the
the those glasses are
those are taught since they're little
okay so you need to try to um we need to
try to
influence that at the maybe at the
earlier stages okay if i pick up a bible
today
the message is there it's very clear i
see
the way i interpret a bible is a little
bit different now
than it was years ago why because
but at the same time if you ask a
you know a christian right
they will read the exact same message
and interpret something different
you see uh there's passages in acts for
example in the bible in which
you know some of
jesus's closest disciples are calling
him a messenger they're calling him
someone sent by god they're not calling
him god these are his closest disciples
and there's that message still in the
bible but the christians they just in
generally speaking they just don't see
it you know it's like they have these
glasses on so
um we need to be more open about it
in i want to share another experience
right and it it butts up to right up to
that i lived in michigan for five years
i was surrounded by middle easterners i
was surrounded by potentially probably a
lot of muslims nobody ever talked to me
about islam wow
living in detroit for five years no one
no one
okay
um
you know i had i had
in the dorms at the university where i
lived i had a friend
who
all would always have this mat on the
floor right and it was always diagonal
and i would always come in and i would
straighten it up and do you think he
ever told me that that's a prayer man no
you see and that's because as muslims i
think that we are shy about that we we
have this uh a little bit of uh
it's either shyness or fear or maybe
lack of knowledge maybe we think that
people are not willing to listen
uh and i think that we need to work on
that as a community as an uma let's be
more open if we put the message out
there if we're open if we're inviting
um then i think that uh a a good portion
of that
populist that calls itself spiritual but
not religious would be turned into islam
very easily it's a natural transition
yeah it's very important to have uh
have this confidence because you're upon
the truth and if you're living the truth
you should be sharing the truth and if
you care you share as i often say so
it's sad to see that you came across so
many muslims hopefully people can watch
this and hear from what you're saying
and
make the same mistake you know yeah i
mean i was i was
going to dearborn i was going to all
these places i was
probably driving by messages left right
and center yeah i think this inferiority
complex it is and it's it's a tendency
to just shy away from it yeah um
maybe i'm not i'm not saying that every
single person or every middle easterner
that i came across up there right um was
a uh you know a real you know practicing
muslim or something like that but
definitely i was surrounded by islam and
i had no idea about it you got some good
coffee in the clubhouse oh yeah
aslanicum brother
so when you become uh after shahada
[Music]
what is your thinking about the jesus
and the prophet muhammad
uh salallahu islam
what is the before what do you think the
jesus now what do you think and what is
that
you're like thinking about the prophet
muhammad sallallahu islam our prophet
so
to
to see if i understood correctly what is
what was my concept of isla salaam
before before taking my shahada and
uh and now how it has changed or how it
has shifted i don't believe my my
personal concept of jesus like islam has
shifted too much
okay i never
really embraced him as a god or part of
god i embrace him as a prophet more than
anything um the uh either that or i
wasn't 100
clear of what he was
but i i would not say that i embraced
him as a god before right and prophet
muhammad peace be upon him i came to
learn more about him after taking
michigan it was just um because of that
censorship by omission it's just not
something or not someone that i you know
uh was able or to be exposed to quite a
bit before beforehand and if you want to
add to that michael yeah
two things
yes
many christian people don't know
jesus's important role in the quran
for example
he does have a miraculous
birth
he
[Music]
mary is touched by the holy spirit
and jesus is conceived
and also
most islamic scholars will agree
that
jesus will come back as the messiah of
course there's a lot of
different ideas about that but the vast
majority
of islamic scholars believe
that jesus will return
as the messiah and he will correct
people
into teaching them that he was a prophet
not the son of god
something i will borrow
from my friend francisco that he
emphasized in our last open house
is that
there must be at least a dozen
translations
of
the new testament there's the new world
edition jehovah's witnesses have their
translation
catholics have theirs
there are certain contradictions in each
and every one of them
however
there is only one translation of the
quran and it has never changed
over time
and i think that says a lot about the
ferocity meaning truth of islam
and i remember you brought that out in
our last open house
that's that's an amazing point that
there is only one version of the quran
tamper-free tamper proof
nothing like it but like you said you
have all these different versions that
are out there
in this bible king james you might have
73 books or what is it uh 66 and then
you go to the do reverse set you know
these seven are thrown out then you go
to the greek orthodox and then you go to
the ethiopian and then you set but the
quran
it is just one that's the amazing thing
something i um something i want to add
is that
i
speaking with a brother um
at the other masjid the other day he's
from palestine and he says he actually
corroborates the version of
uh
let's say of
catholicism or christianity that i was
taught
that
according to him if you go to like
you know a christian village in
philistine in palestine they don't
necessarily believe that jesus is god
you know they believe like i told you
that he is a prophet of god he's
let's say that he's he's a vip he's
elevated right he's not god that's the
bottom line right those are christians
and palestinians are christians in
palestine according to him and he's
palestinian so the uh um
i think that's an interesting thing that
i truly believe that the whole notion of
of trinity as we know it today in the in
the you know
american particularly westerner
christian communities i think that that
is
stronger and has really taken shape here
in the west in you know in evangelical
groups in american christianity stuff
like that but if you go overseas if you
go to probably uh you know the
old school that's called it christianity
they had a different concept and i i
think i want to do more research on that
too you know yeah there was a there's a
new study that came out that this is
just recent that
the study confirmed that over half of
christians 30 percent of evangelicals
don't believe jesus is god
so they're coming closer to islam
inshallah
right last question here with our
brother
abdullah
so how did you perceive muslims and
islam before becoming a muslim and how
did that evolve
after
becoming muslim and
whether your knowledge of islam or
muslims have contributed to you becoming
a muslim
and the question for both of you
beautiful question
how did i perceive
muslims before
becoming muslim
i think that
you know in in in particular in western
media we have you know the the media
agenda that's portraying umbilifying
muslims by and large correct um and then
you also have these horrible images of
you know groups like daesh and all these
other crazy things right but again when
you have
real muslims such as you know
good role models or people like you know
that i was influenced by like muhammad
ali and and others and malcolm x and
such right when you see their behavior
that's what's important because
actually that contrast personally is
what made me research more into islam
because i saw this beautiful person
doing all this beautiful work in
muhammad ali
and
you know all these other beautiful
things about the about the religion and
being warm and
the
you know the the culture overall
and then i saw these people you know
being cruel and cutting off heads in
iraq and syria and all these other
praises i'm like this doesn't make sense
like something is up
that's what that that dichotomy that
that contrast is what made me want to
really research islam on my own you know
and and say okay
let me look upon you because i had no
muslim friends so let me look up on
youtube what's the deal you know let me
look up a muslim sermon let me see what
they actually say
and that's what i did you know it was
because i knew no
or probably i did i just didn't know
that they were muslim you know um my
my source of information became youtube
from the beginning so
the uh so how did it change after
becoming muslim
you know i think it's been a natural
process you know it's been uh it's going
to be close to four years now that since
i took my shahada in april 2018. um the
uh
and the community
has really come forward to to support i
believe my growth but also i think that
when you are
on a spiritual path and when when when
you're looking for knowledge
god makes it easy right when you're
looking for
the right knowledge
allah opens the doors and puts it in
front of you so that you can actually
take and learn and grow
so as long as we're on that path
you know
i want to thank our community for always
being supportive of my journey so far so
it's uh
a very very very interesting question
first off it to african-american people
what i'm going to say
is an exaggeration
american people
love black culture
but
lamentably unfortunately many
american people don't like black people
they love the culture they love the
music
etc etc and then on the other hand
the feelings drop to
negativity and maybe i can draw a
parallel uh
brother francisco mentioned muhammad ali
a great man
i remember even during the vietnam war
when
muhammad ali
refused to serve in the military because
on religious grounds
i didn't hear
a lot of
anti-muslim
expression
and when he came back to box
he was as popular as ever
and then afterwards in his career in his
career as a statesman for the sport and
for world peace
he became very beloved
i'm a big basketball fan
some of my heroes were kareem
abdul-jabbar
uh and uh fsh kanter
who i really adore for
his taking his stand on human rights
and um
elijah won akeem elijah
who
was such a great human being for many
many years
he never signed a license for an
expensive sporting shoe
and people said you're crazy you could
make millions of dollars just
endorse nike adidas whatever
and finally akin said
i don't want poor inner city children
young kids
fighting with each other stealing
from each other or killing
each other for a shoe that has my name
on it so what did he do
instead
he endorsed a 35
shoe with mcgregor
a really
low run brand at target that sold for 35
for the simple reason that
he could rest with his conscience
knowing
that everybody could afford that shoe
and
no
injustice would be committed in his name
for a shoe with his name on it
so uh
yeah there's a lot of
hatred out there
but i i do believe that the majority of
people
in this country
[Music]
live up to their better nature of course
we we read about
the
the hate
against religious institutions
but i believe i still believe with all
of my heart it's the minority of
americans not the majority
i want to thank both of you for being
with us here
and i want to thank the audience
and i want to thank you for tuning in
and
you reminded me of a hadith by the last
federal messenger muhammad who said when
you take a hand span when you come
walking to god god will take ten
hand spans towards you so if you're
somebody who's interested on the way of
life that these two gentlemen
have
chosen
to
accept as their way of life
and you want to know the book that
helped them to make that decision and
you want to get that free quran like our
brother did you can go ahead and tune in
to thedeenshow.com
and you can go ahead and get your free
copy of the quran
and again thank you very much for
sharing your story inshallah i can be a
god almighty is the greatest
and inshallah can be an inspiration
and
it can be a motivation for so many
potential millions who are out there who
are also searching for purpose in life
thank you for your work eddie because it
makes a difference thank you very much
we'll see you next time here on the d
show peace be with you assalamu alaykum
and if you like this episode of the dean
show
like this video
share this video
far and wide and support us on our
patreon page so we can continue this
work
thank you for tuning in peace be with
you assalamu alaikum